hi i'm becca park and i'm also becca
park
and today we're going to be making
kimbap
people use different fillings for their
keempup and you can personalize it with
what you want so some people use
imitation crab or
they'll use tuna or they'll use spam
for ours we're going to be using kugogi
and it's my mom's recipe
gimbap literally means seaweed rice
because keem in korean means dried
seaweed sheet and pop means rice
when i was young we used to call these
rainbow rolls oh you did yeah that's
cute
growing up as a korean american in the
states
i was obsessed with this question of
authenticity of am i authentically
korean or am i korean enough or am i
american enough as so many people of any
diaspora can feel and i think in some
ways it's been very liberating to learn
how to cook that food myself because
i've been able to release that question
of authenticity that's no longer about
striving towards some idealized notion
of what it means to claim your ethnicity
growing up as a korean-american kid in a
predominantly white suburb you know
you're just worried about fitting in so
lunch time and your packed lunches
become a thing especially if i'm
bringing korean food and it was smelly
it was different
it was something that i was ashamed of
back then
and now i feel like i'm reclaiming it
and i'm just so proud of this food
that feeling of shame or feeling
embarrassed that you're not the same as
everyone else
is such a visceral feeling that sticks
with you and it almost has taken all
these years to kind of undo that and i
think
cooking korean food and cooking together
has been about seeing our food through
our eyes and not through anyone else's
when i think about it now it's like oh
there's so much care and love that goes
into making like a lunch like that for
your child
it's kind of like
stepping
into the kitchens of like my
grandmothers because korean food
requires such a level of care for each
ingredient you really taste it like you
taste that this carrot is sauteed
differently than you would this cucumber
and how all those flavors together
create this very tender dish
it's been really beautiful living with
becca because there's just this inherent
sense of comfort of living with a fellow
korean american
where some nights we'll just be watching
trashy reality tv and we'll look at each
other and be like do you want to get a
suitable
you know where you're like okay only you
get it
me too we did that we did it oh yes
[Music]